♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY."
FROM ON THE MIDTERMS, JEFF
SESSIONS RESIGNATION TODAY, WE
GO TO THE GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN,
NUMBER ONE -- BY THE WAY, YOUR
RATINGS WERE A KILO.
ON SUNDAY NIGHT.
THANK ME, LIFE, LIBERTY, AND
LIVE IN, RIGHT ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
LET'S START WITH THE RESULTS, I
WANT TO THREE TOPICS FOR YOU,
YOU CAN GO IN ANY ORDER, I'M ON
YOUR TAKE ON THE RESULTS, YOUR
TAKE ON THE MEDIA, AND YOUR
REACTION TO JEFF SESSIONS'
RESIGNATION TODAY.
SPEAKER YOU KNOW, SEAN, IN MANY
WAYS, IT IS ONE     ONE AND THES
WAYS, IT IS ONE     ONE AND THEM
WAYS, IT IS ONE     ONE AND THEE
THING.
THE MEDIA WERE VERY ANGRY TODAY
AT THAT PRESS CONFERENCE, AND
YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHY, I
THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT THEY SAID
HAD A LOUSY NIGHT, THE DEMOCRATS
TAKE ABOUT 34 SEATS, AND I WANT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THEY HAVE AN 11 MEMBER AND
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE, AND WITH
THAT 11 MEMBER MAJORITY, MOST OF
WHICH ARE REPUBLICAN SEATS,
THEY INTENDED TO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO CRIPPLE THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND CRIPPLE THE
PRESIDENCY, AND I WILL GET BACK
TO THAT IN A MINUTE.
WHAT WE SAW TODAY AND THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS A DISGRACE TO
THIS COUNTRY.
IMAGINE THE WORLD WATCHING WHAT
TOOK PLACE THERE.
THESE KAMIKAZE JOURNALISTS
OBVIOUSLY IN A COORDINATED
ATTACK ON THIS PRESIDENT, THEY
ARE TRYING TO CRIPPLE THIS
PRESIDENCY, THEY ARE TRYING TO
SABOTAGE THIS PRESIDENCY, IT IS
NOT GOING TO WORK, BUT THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY ARE FURIOUS THAT THIS BLUE
WAVE WAS A BLUE TICKLE LAST
NIGHT, BECAUSE THAT IS ALL IT
WAS.
THEY HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BLUE WAVE, THEY HAVE BEEN
BEATING DOWN THIS PRESIDENT,
BEATING DOWN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, BEATING DOWN THESE
CANDIDATES, THEY PULL OUT THEIR
RACIST TOOL TO USE, THERE WIPES
THE PRIMACY TOOL TO USE, THEY
PULL OUT THEIR TOOL TO USE,
THEIR HITLER TOOL TO USE, TRY TO
BECOME A CODE, CAN'T TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BUT IN DEMOCRAT
TALKING POINTS AND THE MEDIA IN
THIS COUNTRY, BECAUSE THEY
ARE ONE OF THE SAME THING.
SURVEY AFTER SURVEY OVER THE
DECADES HAVE SHOWN US THAT MOST
IN THE MEDIA ARE LIBERAL, MOST
LIVE AND OPERATE ON THE EASTERN
SEABOARD AND THE WESTERN
SEABOARD.
LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
NOW IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
LOOK AT THE DIVERSITY OF MARXIST
AND LENINIST, PRETTY MUCH, THE
FINANCE COMMITTEE, MET VACCINE
MODERNS, L.A., THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, JERROLD
NADLER, MANHATTAN.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, ADAM SHIFT.
L.A.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS, HEADING THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, AS WELL, HE
WILL BE FROM WHERE?
BALTIMORE.
AND OF COURSE, YOU HAVE
NANCY PELOSI, SAN FRANCISCO,
IT'S OVER HERE AND OVER HERE.
WHAT ABOUT THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY AND THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY?
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
REPRESENTED BECAUSE THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY IS CONTROLLED BY THESE
HARD-CORE LEFTISTS.
I AM SICK AND TIRED OF THESE
MEDIA TYPES TRYING TO HIJACK
THESE PRESS CONFERENCES.
THESE PRESS CONFERENCES ARE FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
CNN, YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE AN
AUDIENCE, IT IS NOT FOR YOU, IT
IS NOT FOR MSNBC, AND IT IS NOT
FOR EVERY HAREBRAINED, MOUSE
MALCONTENT, LIBERAL DRESSED UP
AS A JOURNALIST, WE HAVE
STANDARDS IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
DOCTORS, FOR LAWYERS, FOR
TRUCK DRIVERS, ELECTRICIANS,
WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS FOR
JOURNALISTS?
JAKE TAPPER WAS A SPOKESMAN FOR
A DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS WOMAN,
THEN HE WAS A SPOKESMAN FOR
HANDGUN CONTROL AND, NOW HE IS A
JOURNALIST.
THERE IS A GUY THAT USED TO WORK
FOR OBAMA WHO WORKS AT CNN, NOW
HE IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
REPORTER.
WHAT ARE THEIR STANDARDS?
THERE ARE NO STANDARDS FOR
JOURNALIST TODAY.
AND THEN WE TELL THE JOURNALIST,
YOU SAY TELL THE PRESIDENT, STOP
SAYING, STOP SAYING THE MEDIA
ARE THE ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
HE IS NOT SAYING THE WHOLE
MEDIA, HE HAS ABOUT A THOUSAND
TIMES.
LET ME TELL THE MEDIA SOMETHING,
THE PRESIDENT'S INTO THE ENEMY
OF THE PEOPLE, EITHER, AND YOU
SHOULD STOP YOUR CAMPAIGN I'M
TRYING TO CRIPPLE HIM AND
DESTROY HIM.
THEY ARE UPSET BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO BLUE WAVE.
THEY ARE UPSET THEY LOST IN
2016, THEY ARE UPSET THEY LOST
IN 2018, AND GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE IN 2020,
TOO.
AS FOR SESSIONS, IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS, DON'T YOU
KNOW?
WHAT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS?
THE PRESIDENT GOT RID OF A
CABINET SECRETARY, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HAS ONLY BEEN TELLING
US FOR TEN MONTHS WHAT HE PLANS
TO DO.
IT IS LIKELY SATURDAY NIGHT
MASSACRE, THEY DRAG OUT JOHN
DEAN, A GUY THAT DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE A LAW LICENSE ANYMORE, THE
GUY ON THE LEFT WHO'S THIRD
TIME, I SEEM TO RECALL, THROUGH
WATERGATE.
NOW HE IS A CONTRIBUTING TO SEE
MSNBC, WHAT DOES HE SAY, IT IS
LIKE THE PRESIDENT IS PLOTTING
TO KILL SOMEBODY AND MURDER.
SO HE GETS RID OF SESSIONS,
WHITE, SO WHAT HAPPENS?
HE HAS AN ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THEN I HEAR
THESE SO-CALLED EXPERTS, HE
CAN'T DO THAT, THERE IS A RULE
OF SUCCESSION -- OF COURSE HE
CAN DO THAT.
MOREOVER, THEY SAY IT IS LIKELY
SATURDAY NIGHT MASSACRE -- HOW?
DID HE FIRE MUELLER?
DID HE ORDER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO FIRE
MUELLER?
DID HE ORDER THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO FIRE
MUELLER?
HE HASN'T ORDERED ANYONE TO DO
ANYTHING TO MUELLER, MUELLER IS
STILL ROAMING THE COUNTRYSIDE
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO PROSECUTE
AND CHALLENGE AND SO FORTH AND
SO ON.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
BUT CHUCK SCHUMER AS THEY ARE, I
THINK WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT POINT.
I HAVE SAID THAT THE MUELLER IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND VIOLATES
THE APPOINTMENT BECAUSE, HE
PROVES MY POINT EVERY DAY.
IF MUELLER WAS LIKE A U.S.
ATTORNEY, THEY WOULDN'T KEEP
SAYING HE IS SEPARATE,
PROTECT HIM, HE IS DIFFERENT, HA
PROTECT HIM, HE IS DIFFERENT, HS
TO REPORT TERMS,
EFFECTIVELY, THAT IS WHY HIS
APPOINTMENT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO GO TO THE
SENATE AND BE CONFIRMED, JUST A
LITTLE NICETY THERE THAT I
WANTED TO MENTION, AS WELL.
IN ANY EVENT, THE REPUBLICANS
HAD A VERY GOOD NIGHT, THEY HAD
A GOOD NIGHT, QUITE FRANKLY,
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT.
IT IS THE PRESIDENT WHO HELD THE
SENATE, AND SOME OF THESE
EXCELLENT CANDIDATES, AND THE
LOSSES IN THE HOUSE COULD HAVE
BEEN WORSE.
BUT THEY WEREN'T WARES.
AND THAT IS WHY THE MEDIA ARE
FURIOUS, SEAN, THAT IS THE
BOTTOM LINE.
AND I'M GOING TO TELL THE MEDIA
SOMETHING.
YOU ARE HUMILIATING YOURSELF,
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVES,
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVEST
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESE
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESA
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESI
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESN
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESP
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESO
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVESL
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING YOURSELVES,
MORE AND MORE ARE TURNING ON
YOU, NOT BECAUSE OF THE
PRESIDENT SAYS YOU ARE THE ENEMY
OF THE PEOPLE, BUT BECAUSE YOU
ACT LIKE THE ENEMY OF THE
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE LEARNED IN THIS
PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY THANKS TO
THE MEDIA?
NOTHING.
A PRESIDENTIAL PRESS CONFERENCE
ISN'T FOR CNN, WHICH DOESN'T
HAVE ANY VIEWERS, ANYWAY, IT IS
WHERE WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU ASK QUESTIONS TO ELICIT
INFORMATION FROM OUR PRESIDENT
SO WE CAN KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, MARK, I PUT
UP BARACK OBAMA IN HIS FIRST
MIDTERM, 69 HOUSE AND SENATE
SEATS.
BILL CLINTON, 60.
THREE TIMES, IT HAS HAPPENED
WHERE A PRESIDENT IS FURNISHED
MIDTERM WINS AS MANY SEATS, THAT
IS AT.
>> THEY ARE LIBERALS, THEY ARE
DEMOCRATS, THEY LIKE THEM, SO
THEY GET TREATED QUITE
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Sean: GREAT ONE, WE CALL
YOU THE GREAT ONE FOR A REASON.